nice patience there by lebron just
really rocking draymond green to sleep
on that shot
curry way outside with a three got it
green picks up number one steph curry
now 141 made threes for the duke he puts
it up and through and that's what he's
going to bring off the bench here curry
running three
he's at two
bill that's a three very big part of
that win
look at this
[Music]
to have that communication between
players especially guys like kawhi
and that staff curry three got it that
was over justice winslow who just
checked in for la is something else what
a display
steph curry with the step back long
three
chef curry cooking iggy's got the ball
here comes curry lee is on the wing and
curry with another
up this three different
this is going to be some kind of display
and this crowd is already feeling it
with what he's done from disc been real
quiet offensively in the second half
under two
green is in a torture chamber and
outside it goes curry three
another one
40 points for curry another turnover by
golden state way outside 40-footer right
wow here comes curry
ahead it goes to lee back to step for
the lead
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he is so confident right now both from
outside and inside
and they just moving the ball well got
multiple drives staff
it was the draymond drive and then just
hitting curry for the three he did it
perfectly just stab at the drive make
sure you can get back out draymond gets
into the paint
he and steph i said curry has eight for
the doves
this has been a solid quarter by
sacramento get the two deep three with
the two for one you called it before it
was even out of his hand i still can't
believe cavan looney is 25 years old
they both jumped way too early this is
year seven for kevon and he's 25.
steph curry for three there it is yeah
they did it again there and they got
what they wanted but it didn't work out
final minute of the third
curry three quiets the crowd tristan
wasn't out there in time it's that same
split action to come off a screen your
teammate got a piece of your man that
neck was a weakness a year ago
steph is still moving
and catch and shoot three and
gary payton two has figured out
something and that's just you know 100
points once in three games
and 34 already as steph is foul shooting
at three and an opportunity for a
four-point play video game mode
activated under control when you're
lunging forward trying to contest his
shot got him on the arm and didn't give
him a place to land when steph is gonna
be going for 10 10 and seven
um when your leader is rebounding like
that you better not be slacking and
curry with the three
makes someone help looney had to help
there
[Music]
just played him like a piano get two for
one here if you want it andre knows that
so does steph
there's the free
[Applause]
let me say best shooter ever
how many guys shoot one foot runners
from 25 feet anthony melton's going come
on even he's impressed like what did i
just do
makes it look so easy so otto porter has
checked in
step open three
stephen adams does not want to come out
there and guard stephen curry
luke is known as the defender we've seen
the offense get better but he's still
only 20 from beyond the arc
steph curry is not 20
she loves steph moving without the ball
watch that screen bone crushing lou dort
if you're holding lou dorado he says no
lou dort
let me go against somebody different
that should be a great game against the
lakers on espn
tied at 50.
curry lines it up
and that's
dangerous and the meter's still running
lead is only 10. but think about back in
the day right three days off that's two
days of two hour two and a half hour
practice
curry walking it into the front court
hurry launches guys
the nba's leading scorer steph curry
only needs a sliver of light
curry with a hand in his face still able
to hit from downtown contest steph turns
sideways and heaves it basically with
one hand that's a shot he practices he
works on it it's easy for him
that's ridiculous
curry step back weights fly by three oh
yeah
doing a great job of setting screens and
creating opens if you're valentino's you
got to stay up there and let the help
behind you take the elites of fox
valentine's out really well
[Applause]
and when he's wide open like this
oh no
his uncle a huge influence saw this
coaching career coming for willie even
before willie did
curry
[Music]
no one else is moving either so he's
just thinking i got to make something
happen here
snapped a good look at it
curry's got a dozen and the haircut is
working if you're just sitting at the
end of the bench and you never get to
play in games
teams don't practice as much
as they used to
step back
[Applause]
[Music]
is saying please keep
[Music]
his body didn't stay connected looney
the offensive rebound off the pool
missed
[Applause]
don't set a screen for steph let him
work on her
like that
finding that compete level
and their leader is doing it all
probably didn't see that contact
so you can't blow the whistle
the back this is the step three again no
one
close enough to draymond so steph comes
off there
quick will push
can you expand this lead step three
[Music]
lead i'm going at herder's head this
dude cannot guard me
off the dribble
and it's not reaching trying to move his
feet
defense reddish is right up on him no
air space steph saying i don't need much
air space
such a quick release
andrew wiggins
trench coat tonight on it
for the step back three
48
to hell out to the three-point line as
well knock him down
[Applause]
[Applause]
maybe not blocking probably getting him
on the arm but the step back his step
backs are so mean
it's the human torch
i've been really looking forward to
watching the bulls in person for the
first time they've been so fun as curry
launches
[Applause]
setting the tone the first play sets the
cross screen
now he comes down good job not settling
at that three-point line sells the shot
fake and then puts his head down and
attacks a lot of contact there curry for
three
that's his third
this can be discouraging when you play
this type of defense and a guy
just shows his greatness little upper
body strength for the three-point shot
this bull's all so far this season
they've been gritty and tough curry
another three got it
26 for curry
this really is how about this
steph curry says allow me to have this
dance and that's draymond green it was a
terrific story in the athletic marcus
thompson and darnold mayberry wrote
about how these two is curry launches
the three knocks it down
derek jones
let's get a little sloppy wiggins kicks
it out curry puts up a three
it's good steph curry from downtown he's
got 40.
the final three seconds
charlotte with the first
curry to end the third
baked it in
he banked it in and it's gonna count
points including four threes curry first
of all great
movie without the basketball there but
when kevin durant gets into the paint
with his length and touch
it's pretty much automatic
[Applause]
curry for the answer okay and so
curry with hardened autumn shakes him
another beautiful pass green went for
the extra pass into the hands of curry
rattles one home for three
exits with two fouls
andre iguodala on the floor for the
first time back with the warriors
all of his teammates rave about what he
has brought back to the picture is curry
[Applause]
look who's there for the rebound that's
peyton
curry again almost the same spot oh
rattles one home
[Applause]
on fire pulling up from deep in
transition two guys guarding them it
doesn't matter
all steph all day
golden state
up
early when you try to play on top of
durant with the ball out top they're
just going to throw them all over the
rim you just can't do that
well blake griffin's getting tired of
this switch i think that's the third one
that curry has hit on him tonight
a minute and a half into this fourth
quarter
curry lets it fly and right to the
bottom it goes now do you know how hard
that is right there and now he got him
set curry hits the three
they're back up 21 their defenses look
better the last two possessions
[Applause]
the warriors play at such a quicker pace
than cleveland curry just steps into the
triples got a dozen
deals to looney
now green
[Applause]
curry goes and gets it and cans of three
everybody can hear it everybody knows
okay got to attack shot clock's running
down better you butter shoot the ball
and let that guy shoot the ball he
better shoot it
i want to get a good shot here
[Applause]
the lead
sitting at six
curry making it nine he's a flame
thrower
nine threes for the 38th time in his
career